would like to
in that they representation was made
about athlete's verification
I'm training from a responsible
Authority
in position conditions
there was a further representation made
um
uh amazing issues about the then company
director I would like to work in the
United Kingdom
the stunt raises raised two issues the
first was
permanently and not an individual and
therefore companies registered
several otherwise
um and then the second issue uh was that
in any events
the company's house should be brought
this in your general page 77 78 uh
Records that the personal name from that
objections
with uh with removed from the company
and it has been replaced so the issue
ceases to invest my advice to your
relation to the application
the
is that there was evidence received
in traffic
um using the political ruler
prior to this licensing application
being determined
it is right and only crowd to say is
that the company also calls and held
accountability sales
an excellent premises for business
premises have software consultant
um
however there is no
the license which appears to be being
used for the sales from the Trafford
address was not covered by a United
license
is
received within the approval at the time
and therefore you should take you know
accounts of it
um
to prosecuted for any offenses that
arise license
[Music]
it would
also in my opinion they looked into you
to
ask the company for representative
I understand that the absence of this
clients I'm sorry you're going to feel
free
my name is Nick Nick server from the
licensing girls
questions
may be to deal with the application as
it stands on its safe and those require
a
representations to be made to the most
specific places within 14 days
the situation has not always in order
that's a program
thank you and a couple of questions
doing first it is if we were to
insist on a representation
to explain this position so we have to
be safe
this is
on the master of the services
representation
it is
I've got a couple of things to say
[Music]
thank you thanks very much
very helpful
approach to it what I would say is this
okay it's not a representation
between the appropriate time and
therefore
it does not have under the licensing act
and devices
I've got to say firstly representative
reference is not here to corroborate the
spirit how to make sense to contact this
person and in the absence of an email
address
my investigations have I'm afraid to
proved fruits as to the circumstances of
this delivery attentive pain are
attentive to transactions all you can
say is that this could when indeed to be
an error of address attribution
this is the process
license certainly by page two of a
statement
um
so that's uh that's all that so so it
has been put right made
okay nothing was ever sold or supplied
now the offense is that that other latch
is therefore incorrect as incomplete
fifthly the output is not here to be an
explanation now I have to take
restrictions that will explain my
instructions I'm very respectful to
answer this license
sexually no representations have been
made against the application not a
responsible authorities and the
originator for this piece of detective
work which establishes as a problem with
deliverable it doesn't start to change
criminal offense at all
it is most probably competitive
and they are not here and their evidence
cannot be tested
and therefore
what I'm asking people is that we do
indeed grab a license this evening and
if there are any further investigations
clarifications needed interventions by
the end portions of authorities that
they can be conducted
great section 51 review procedure under
the license
remedial action and of course the way to
help
life notified
[Music]
but in the meantime
having explained those subsequence from
this articles fully as I can I I I'm
this lessons okay and if there are
problems are streaming you and I can
deal with them on another one
system operation or established okay
but the offenses
license
[Music]
issue is delivering a tribute to the
wrong device I like their mission is
explanation of all things the tech
perhaps should be at the time that
that's attentive which is a sentence of
one with
synonyms I think was ever sold or
supplied although maybe expose
thank you
just so that I can get one of them
in for a few minutes
but she said